Hey Thoughty2 Here.
Do you ever talk to yourself?
No, not out loud, in your mind.
I’m talking about that little voice in your
head that often chips in throughout the day
to offer up some useful advice.
You know, the one that’s saying “I hate
you” over and over again whilst your boss
is giving you a mighty fine rollicking.
Sometimes we even have entire conversations
with ourselves in our heads.
We can also hear it when we read, it’s as
if our mind is saying the words out loud but
only you can hear it.
What causes that little voice inside your
head and what’s its purpose?
Let’s find out.
You might call it Barbara or Keith but scientists
actually have a proper name for the voice
in your head.
It’s called “inner speech” and it’s
been a topic of extensive research for centuries.
Psychologists in particular have been obsessed
with it ever since psychology began.
In the 1930s Russian psychologist Lev Vygotsky
put forward the case that inner speech is
a result of the internalisation of external
speech.
Or to put it in other words, he thought that
inner speech is the exact same process as
external speech, right up until the point
where noise exits our mouth.
There may be some truth to this theory.
In the nineties neuroscientists used neuroimaging
techniques to discover that an area of the
brain called “Broca’s area” which is
responsible for fine motor skills involved
with speech, was active during inner speech
as well as normal speech.
This means that the muscles and organs that
move when we speak, such as the larynx, also
move when we speak to ourselves in our minds,
despite there being absolutely no reason for
such muscles and organs to do so.
This can only mean that the systems in our
brain that govern external speech and inner
speech are very closely linked or maybe even
the same.
The two systems are so intrinsically linked
for good reason.
Because inner speech is actually a prediction
of what we’re about to say.
Researcher Mark Scott at the Department of
Linguistics at the University of British Columbia
led a stud which explored a brain signal known
as “corollary discharge”.
This signal is a copy of a motor signal that
is sent to the brain to alert the brain that
we are about to move, so the brain knows to
react accordingly and most importantly not
to overreact.
The purpose of corollary discharge is to separate
sensory experiences that come from outside
our body and ones that we produce ourselves.
It allows our brain to predict our own movements
before we actually make them.
This is why we can’t tickle ourselves.
Because, before you even start to tickle yourself
a corollary discharge signal has already been
sent to your brain to alert it that you’re
about to tickle yourself and so your brain
completely ignores the sensation of being
tickled.
The system is primarily used to determine
the difference between an external threat
and something that we do ourselves and should
therefore be considered non-threatening.
Our brain utilises corollary discharge in
a very ingenious way when we speak.
If corollary discharge didn’t exist, when
we talk our voice would be overwhelmingly
loud.
Because our ears are so close to the source
of the sound, our own voice would appear so
loud that it would drown out every other noise
around us, and we wouldn’t be able to hear
anything but our own voice and no matter how
much some people love the sound of their own
voice, that would get bloody annoying.
However, when we speak corollary discharge
is used to predict that we are going to produce
a noise and so our brain dampens the sound
of that noise.
The result is that our own voice sounds quieter
to us than to everyone else.
Amazingly our brain does this self-voice filtering
without affecting the volume of voices from
other people.
So why do we have a voice inside our heads?
Ours brains are able to plan sentences in
our minds before we actually say them.
The brain is also really good at replaying
sounds we’ve heard before.
Try imagining any sound you’ve heard before
throughout your life, be it a police siren
or birds tweeting.
When you think about these past sounds you
can actually hear it, it’s almost as if
it’s being replayed inside your head.
So when our brain plans a sentence it replays
the sentence inside our head, and this is
what we refer to as the voice in our head,
or inner speech.
Because of corollary discharge the brain knows
which sentences should be spoken out loud
and which are meant for our ears only and
therefore should be replayed as inner speech
in our mind.
The brain heavily utilises inner speech when
we read because it helps our brain to better
understand the words on the page and remember
them.
Scientists believe people with dyslexia have
a harder time reading and understanding words
because they have no inner voice.
It may be hard to imagine but most dyslexic
people don’t understand the concept of a
voice inside their head, because they quite
simply don’t have one, they instead visualise
and understand everything in pictures instead
of words.
For most people inner voice is an automatic
process and we can hear it every minute of
the day, narrating our lives, planning and
predicting what we’re about to say and communicating
to us what we are reading in real-time.
Some dyslexic individuals have no grasp of
this concept and simply don’t experience
it, that’s why they often move their mouths
whilst reading, because they don’t have
the luxury of a voice inside their head reading
it for them, to help them to easier understand
the text.
Young children do the exact same thing because
we don’t develop the skill of an inner voice
until later on in childhood.
Until children learn this skill they tend
to say everything out loud, for better or
for worse.
It may at times seem like a little devil inside
your head, coercing you to do unruly things,
perhaps telling you to “punch your boss
in the face, go on do it”.
But it is in fact just your brain planning
and even predicting what you’re about to
say, even if you don’t end up actually saying
it.
Because it may be the case that only you need
to hear it, and let’s be honest that’s
usually for the best.